if you were to give advice to a young
person today about life
what would you tell him
if he takes
life with the same mentality
that i do if he has the same
taste of things that i have
i would tell him you know for for
for sport for life in general i would
say
if you will have a dream
you know like
make everything in your power and work
very hard you know never
take no for an answer and go through
hell
in order to achieve it
don't work hard only but work
smart that's i think the problems with a
lot of
people they work hard they can work hard
they burn themselves they don't work
smart
whether it is in in science and business
they make bad choices or they're badly
informed
in sport how many guys i've seen ruin
their career in the gyms
they they spar so hard they they ruined
themself in the gyms they leave their
career in the gyms
i would say to for example because my
field of expertise and
it's in sport of mixed martial art
i would say to you
young kid make your training
playful you know when you get ready for
for competition you need to train to
recreate those
elements that makes you go outside of
your comfort zone
but in every day's life in general
make your training playful don't makes
it like a
hardcore competition about who's who's
winning who's losing make make it
playful
so it will increase your
because you you will not be afraid of
getting hurt or losing
you will be ten to trying more things
and be you it will make you become more
create
creative
you